etymology semantics and meaning change
so far we followed the trail of various
forms of a word as it changed over time
but just stating that for example Queen
became Queen ignores one crucial aspect
an aspect that initially attracts most
amateur enthusiasts of etymology
semantics when it comes to etymology
semantics deals with the meaning of
words and parts of words now semantics
tends to be fuzzy in two ways first the
relationship between the meaning of a
word and its form is generally opaque
second the semantic relationship between
word forms given that their meaning is
known and even between word roots and
words derived from those same roots
through word formation is approximate
and variable consider the relationship
between the meaning of house and the
meaning of home or the etymological re
in remain verses in reappear we cannot
simply set semantic relatedness to true
or false we have to be aware of and
capture the gradations of meaning like
sound in form meaning changes over time
we can classify meaning changes in two
types abstract or from concrete general
to or from specific temporal to or from
locative we can also consider the origin
of a meaning change or the influence of
languages for example calyx calcs form
when speakers borrow patterns found in
another language to express a meaning
rather than borrow the Latin express
expression weõll actia for our galaxy
English speakers Celt we are lack that
as a new native term Milky Way
other times semantic loans occur when a
language uses pre-exists
a pre-existing word or phrase to cover a
borrowed meaning we can also talk about
meaning and use words in use maybe this
to be described as literary poetic
archaic
obsolete obsolescent jargon colloquial
slang preferred and so on but however we
classify it semantic change is not as
systematic as sound change under the
regularity hypothesis we expect that it
for example if the Africa
became Z in a language words that once
began with that Z will now start with Z
don't expect the same from say an
abstract to concrete semantic change not
all abstract meanings will become
concrete in a language a last note about
meaning change the basic core vocabulary
of a language contains words that tend
not to be replaced and whose meanings do
not shift as much as the name implies
these words include basic terms like
family members terms for for Earth Sun
and other words learned early and often
let's go back and look at our etymology
of Queen you saw that the word came from
Old English Queen let's add our
semantics in Old English that word meant
woman what's more the proto-germanic
word Quinn is and most cognates and
other indo-european languages like Greek
goon a mean woman or wife it's safe to
say that the proto-indo-european root
Wayne also meant woman this is an
example of meaning change the meaning
shifts from general woman to a more
specific female monarch as you read
etymologies or build an etymology there
are some conventions worth noting the
source language word and meaning are
indicated for earlier attested forms
parts of speech are sometimes given such
as noun adjective or verb language names
are abbreviated and dates and sources
support more thorough etymologies the
complex relationships between cognates
and dialects are bored boiled down to
clear examples with relevant semantic
information given for each example
either by choosing the most
representative attested word or by
citing a reconstructed ancestral form
comparative examples are also cited
again reconstructions are marked with an
asterisk and words are traced back as
far as possible sometimes an etymology
becomes unclear contested in which case
the uncertainty is mentioned and the
multiple possible origins are cited for
instance there are double etymologies in
cases of influence the English noun fuse
comes from Italian food
but its etymology was influenced by the
French word Susy let's conclude this
discussion of etymology by considering
the context in which we may stumble upon
etymologies you'll often find
etymologies and major dictionaries
following definitions of many words you
can also get your hands on dictionaries
of proto-language root words if you're
interested in doing etymology and
reverse determining the words that have
descended from some root word in a
specific reconstructed language like
proto-indo-european or proto mayan a
common source of etymologies is folk
etymology the popular telling and
retelling of the stories behind the word
folk etymologies often focus on names
and popular phrases like mind your P's
and Q's of course full genome ologies
are not always factually correct but
more importantly they're never accurate
enough to count as thorough linguistic
etymologies folk etymologies are
interested in storytelling entertainment
and credibility not precision and
evidential support speaking of names
automatic studies the etymology of
proper names automatics is different
because the meaning of words that turn
into names tend to become vestigial the
name proper comes to refer to the
identity of a person or place but the
etymology still interests even
non-specialists what's more words
derived from the same source can change
in different ways when they're used as a
proper noun names may be more
conservative over time or capture the
history of borrowings and interactions
with surrounding languages for example
the French name Jacques preserves an old
nominative singular case ending s which
common nouns lost in French the Spanish
name Rodrigues contains a Visigothic
root with the patronymic suffix that's
all for this introduction to etymology I
hope it's helped you understand
entomology from a linguistic perspective
you can see that while an etymology
won't tell you what the word actually
means that's determined by how speakers
of a language use that word it does tell
the sometimes fascinating and unexpected
history of the development of words in a
language the next time you hear look up
in an etymology you'll be able to take a
more critical and rigorous look at the
origin of a word